wir wissen heute geht es den meisten bei
der video ist darum euch zum lachen zu
bringen wir sehen hier lustige schräge
videos machen unsere witze darüber
lachen uns einen ab und so weiter und so
fort aber leute aber ihr wisst auch dass
wir zwischendurch auch wichtig ist mal
inhalte zu bringen also meine reichweite
nicht dafür zu nutzen euch zum lachen zu
bringen was ich sehr gerne mache sondern
zusätzlich auch noch irgendwas
mitzugeben was euch im leben vielleicht
was bringen kann warum sage ich dass
leute ich hab ein paar tage auf einem
kanal direction auf die mobbing
vergangenheit einer germany's next
topmodel teilnehmerin gemacht und sehr
interessanter weise haben gewitter im
kopf also tim und jan ein video gemacht
wo sie auch über ihre vergangenheit und
probleme der vergangheit erzählen und da
gibt es auch ein paar zu mobbing und auf
den reagieren wir jetzt gucken wir sind
jetzt noch da und einfach mal darüber zu
reden was uns so in letzter zeit so ein
bisschen belastet hat oder vielleicht
doch allgemein weil normalerweise redet
man nicht unbedingt über solche themen
so ist es nämlich leute und das ist
durchaus ein problem was ich einmal auch
nicht ganz verstehe also zum bestimmt
ein stechen stück war nicht sehr viele
youtuber schrecken davor zurück solche
themen auch anzusprechen auf jedem kanal
und die allermeisten würde einfach ein
gebot nee ich will einfach mit meinem
kanal einfach nur die leute unterhalten
ich habe irgendwie auch angst davor dass
preiszugeben oder darüber zu reden ich
trau mich das nicht aber es ist eben
sehr wichtig auch sowas zu machen damit
alle leute die in ihrem leben
irgendwelche probleme haben und sich
damit schlecht fühle deswegen schlecht
fühlt was sehr sehr viele sind sehen hey
guck mal da ist ja mal den mag ich der
unterhält mich dann finde ich cool aber
der ist auch nur menschen dinge gibt es
auch gut und ich glaube damit fühlen
sich die leute verbessern mit ihren
sachen und deswegen ist es sehr wichtig
ich hatte ja auch so eine phase damals
in der schule wo ich
auch längere zeit nicht in die schule
gegangen bin ich dabei sind von der
fünften bis zur sechsten klasse kommen
krass also die story hinter ist die die
jungs erzählen zwei verschiedene
geschichten oder von zwei problemen die
sie hatten jan von seinen panikattacken
und themen eben von seiner mobbing
vergangenheit und scheinbar ging er
einfach da eine lange zeit gar nicht in
die schule so werde es jetzt gerade
gesagt hat das ist quasi so war es bei
mir nicht also wenn ich morgens
aufgewacht bin und ich hatte noch zwei
arme und zwei beine dann musste ich in
die schule geht ja das war halt weil ich
auch problemen wünschen wieder nachts
also dort wurde dann mich so ziemlich
verkochen ich habe ihn gemacht bei denen
endlich das ist ja was ist echt crazy
leute also ist es ist echt crazy das
zusehen und bisschen was auch crazy es
leute damals ich erinnere mich noch hat
man sich einfach so klein gefühlt so
schlecht gefühlt so unerwünscht
ungeliebt auch weitere jetzt gucke jetzt
guckt euch das mal an glücklich über die
jungs haben nicht immer die einfachste
zeit gab in ihrem leben und ja jetzt
haben wir einfach einen der krassesten
youtube kanäle in deutschland leute also
kann es wirklich nur sagen auch wenn es
gerade sagt geht euch nicht auf macht
das nicht immer magenschmerzen hatte
wenn ich schon daran gedacht hatte die
schule zu gehen und mich dann einfach so
ziehen
ich hab zu hause fühlen völlig offen
nicht eingeschlossen haben völlig und
hat mit niemandem darüber reden wollte
noch niemand erzählt was los ist fühle
ich fühle ich fühle ich fühle ich wenn
man einfach so denkt so war
wer soll da helfen also weil man über
die erfahrung gemacht die eigenen eltern
den erlebt man das aber die können wir
auch nicht so wirklich was machen oder
check nicht ernst ist das so wie es im
letzten video schon gesagt habe die
lehrer sowieso nicht kommen also aber zu
diesem bauchschmerzen in die schule zu
gehen findet sich 1000% leute ich will
jetzt hier wirklich offen seien ist auch
für mich nicht ganz leicht weil ich euch
jetzt wirklich sehr private sachen
erzählen aber ich erinnere mich an ein
mal da ging es darum nach den
schulferien wieder in die schule zu
gehen und ich erinnere mich immer noch
sehr bildlich hatte an diesem tag ich
habe wirklich in meinem zimmer so
gefühlten nervenzusammenbruch gehabt
geheult und klar war ich einfach nicht
mehr in diese schule wollte weil das mit
wem ich die mich so fertig gemacht haben
eine komplett verzweifelt war nicht
bewusst was sind wir machen sind meine
mutter doch angst hatte dass irgendwas
passiert wenn ich nicht in die schule
gehen
was sollen sie machen wenn ich nicht
will weil so die war halt ein bisschen
hilflos
ich kann dir sagen also ich kann dir
sagen was meine mutter gemacht hat oder
mein vater respekt auch an seine eltern
respekt dass hier deine situation also
ernst genommen aber meine eltern hatten
einfach ob es jedoch wirklich irgendwann
hat sie dann gott sei dank diesen
schritt und diesen gut aufgefasst habe
schwerste super weil ich halte die ganze
geholt haben italien gewährt habe nicht
so ein bisschen und therapeuten zu
schicken beziehungsweise und
therapeutische klinik sogar damals ja ja
ja ist auch da fand ich auch gemacht
habe ich war auch einmal lange zeit
sogar in therapie aber das ist auch
wieder ein so wichtiger punkt leute auch
wirklich an die leute die die so
wirklich struggle in ihrem leben holt
euch hilfe safe say say say say say die
leute die durch ihr leben gehen und
jeder tag ist irgendwie einfach schlecht
so aber auch über eine lange zeit hinweg
dann holt euch hilfrich dass das ist
nicht normal ich bin auch kein
psychotherapeut aber wenn über einen
ausgedehnten zeitraum ist einfach nicht
so nice ist dann könnt ihr euch da auch
hilfe holen findet da habe ich dann auch
irgendwann genauso darüber zu reden dass
das ok ist so seine emotionen
rauszulassen
da somit jemand dazwischen rechnen muss
wenn man mit niemandem über sowas
spricht und das alles in sich hinein
dass ich glaube dann ist wirklich so
dass man da irgendwann nicht mehr selber
auskommt und infekt und und wie ich
schon gesagt habe ist man muss es
erstmal lernen interessanterweise muss
erst mal lernen über die eigenen
emotionen zu reden das ist gar nicht so
leicht das war auch ein thema wo ich
eines tages betrachter so das war
wirklich ein langer prozess bis ich
angefangen habe mit diesem therapeuten
zu reden soll wie sagst wirklich wochen
monate da und ich habe einfach in der
eingang war mein hotel junge die dahin
ist okay bist du einfach nichts gesagt
ich saß da und war so und deswegen
freuen dann kann ich euch nur sagen
falls irgendwelche probleme habt und
auch wenn ihr catwalk ab und irgendwas
mit leuten zu gehen und mit ihm reden
über freunde vielleicht dann sucht euch
irgend jemand mit dem man darüber reden
kann
fact or expected das ist das ist
wirklich egal was auch immer es ist
leute manchmal hat man diese sache in
seinem kopf drin und man verbrennt sich
da drin und denkt so durch mein ganzes
leben ist es schnell ich war aber was
auch immer und es zieht ein so komplett
runter und wenn man es einmal
ausgesprochen hat einer anderen person
gegenüber und von der person feedback
bekommt oder nicht mal dass man einfach
nur die worte ausgesprochen hat und ist
im raum ist auf einmal sieht man dass so
viel klarer leute redet wirklich mit
anderen leuten und wenn ihr wirklich in
so einer richtig krasse situation sind
dass wir mit niemanden der familie
darüber reden können vielleicht keine
freunde hat mit ihnen darüber reden
kennt keiner anderen person gibt zum
beispiel auch die telefonseelsorge noch
die nummer aber richtig in die
beschreibung eingepackt also ich glaube
man kann den meisten fällen wirklich
jemanden finden den man von seinen
problemen erzählen kann was bei mir auch
damals das problem wahr ist dass ich
mich dann immer das hat sie mit so einer
kleinen sache angefangen die so zwischen
jemand er ist ein freund damals waren
dann hat er noch andere leute mit
reingezogen ich habe mich immer weiter
da rein gesteigert meint es sei ihnen
ganze schule hasten welche kicker kann
nicht 1000% raleigh wahrscheinlich hat
das wirklich was mit dieser erfahrung zu
tun die dem gemacht hatte ich auch
gemacht habe dass man einfach wenn so
kleinere negative sachen passiert im
alter dann so negativ strudel kommt also
keine ahnung irgendwie irgendwo person
gibt ein ganz kleines zeichen von
ablehnung es muss gar nichts riesig groß
sein und das befördert ein auch so ein
negativtrend und vor allem mal konnten
dann und am boden an von diesem trend
denkt die ganze welt hast ein also das
kann ich bestätigen leute klasse hat
mich im endeffekt nicht so war
die sache ist nämlich leute das problem
ist wenn man so krasse kassen negative
sachen in seinem leben erlebt hat und zu
krass negatives feedback bekommen von
leuten wie zum beispiel wie man sich
gegen das bekommt wenn man gemobbt wurde
in der schulzeit dann ist manchmal
manchmal die eigene sicht auf einen
selbst nicht mehr richtig versteht wenn
man sich meine leute die ist zu negativ
und man geht immer vom schlimmsten fall
aus dann steht hier also wenn eine
person irgendwas sagt aber irgendwie
irgendwas tut was eigentlich
doppeldeutig ist wenn man mal kritisch
darüber nachdenkt nimmt man eigentlich
immer oder oftmals geld die negativste
auslegung von dieser sache an befördert
sich damit selbst ins abseits weil man
einfach so eine negative vorprägung hat
und da kannst du zb wieder helfen auch
mit dem therapeuten darüber zu reden
genau das system gerade eben meinte das
ist auch ein sehr sehr wichtiger punkt
der für mich als youtuber zumindest also
er meinte dass leute seine videos sehen
oder ihre videos 10 und mehrwert daraus
ziehen können dass sie solche sachen
ansprechen das ist mir persönlich auch
sehr wichtig klar leute man kann seinen
youtube kanal so auslegen dass man immer
die turbo meisten klicks mit allen
sachen macht und man aber ist am ende
nicht die frage wie einen die leute in
erinnerung behalten und ich muss ehrlich
sagen ich bin sehr sehr froh wenn
zumindest ein paar dutzend vielleicht
paar hundert mich in der rede halten ich
war in einem sehr schlechten punkt in
meinem leben hier ging es nicht gut aber
dadurch dass die basler diese themen
angesprochen hat und nicht verschwiegen
hat ging es mir dann besser und ich habe
den weg für mich selbst gesehen das sind
die sache auf die es wirklich ankommt
heute finde ich also wie gesagt leute
mit leuten reden sich professionelle
hilfe zu holen das ist überhaupt keine
schande oder man schaut dort an die
jungs von gewitter im kopf sehr gut dass
sie solche thema auch ansprechen und
schafft dieses videos vereiniger draußen
hilfe ihr kriegt hier einfach
vorgestellt video könnt ihr euren
charakter aus